today I'm delighted to introduce us our
final guest speaker
um Bean Kim
um being Kim is a staff research
scientist at Google brain if you're
really into googleology you know those
funny words the beginning like staff
sort of says how senior you are
um and that means that being's a good
research scientist
um
um so uh I I discovered at lunch today
that bean started out
um studying mechanical engineering at
Seoul national university but she moved
on to uh I don't know if it's better
things or not but she moved on to
computer science and did a PhD
um at MIT and there she started working
on the interpretability and
explainability of machine learning
models
um I think she'll be talking about some
different parts of her work but a theme
that she's had in some of her recent
work that I find especially appealing as
an NLP person is the idea that we should
be using higher level human
interpretable languages for
communication between people and
machines and so welcome Bean looking
forward to your talk
um and go for it thank you thank you
thanks for having me it's honored to be
here it's the rainiest Stanford I've
ever seen last night I got here last
night but then I'm I live in Seattle so
this is pretty common so I still was
able to see the blue sky today I was
like this works I really like it here so
today I'm going to share some of my
dreams chasing my dreams to communicate
with machines
so if you're in this class you probably
agree you don't have to that large
language models and generated models are
pretty cool they're impressive but you
may also agree that they're a little bit
frightening
not just because they're impressive
they're doing really good job but also
we're not quite sure where we're going
with this technology in 10 years out
will we look back and say that
technology was net positive or we will
say ah that was catastrophic we didn't
know that that would happen
and ultimately what I would like to do
or maybe hopefully what we all want to
do is to have this technology benefit us
humans I know in 10 years time or maybe
well 20 years or earlier he's gonna ask
me he's gonna be like Mom did you work
on this AI stuff I watched some of your
talks
and did you know that how this will
profoundly change our lives
and what did you do about that
and I have to answer that question and I
really hope that I have some good things
to say to him
so my initial thought or an instill so
or current thought is that if we want
our ultimate goal to be benefit Humanity
why not directly optimize for it why
wait
so how can we benefit there's lots of
different ways we can benefit but one
way we can benefit is to treat this like
a colleague you know a colleague who are
really good at something
it's called it's not perfect but it's
good at something enough that you want
to learn something from them
one difference is though in this case is
that this colleague is kind of weird
this colleague might have very different
values it might has very different
experiences in the world it may not care
about surviving as much as we do maybe
mortality isn't really a thing for this
colleague
so you have to navigate that in our
conversation
so what do you do when you first meet
somebody there's someone so different
what do you do
you try to have a conversation
to figure out what how do you do what
you do how are you solving decades-old
protein folding problem
how are you so how are you beating the
world gold champion
so easily What It Seems
are you using the same language the
science knowledge the language that we
use atoms molecules or do you think
about the world in a very different way
and more importantly how can we work
together
I have a one area that I really want to
talk to and it's alphago
so alphago beat world of gold Champion
Isador in 2016. Isidore is from South
Korea I'm from South Korea I watched
every single batch it was such a big
deal in South Korea and worldwide I hope
and in one of the matches alphago played
this move called move 37. how many
people watched alphago match matches
and how many people remember move 37.
yeah a few people right and I remember
the nine Don commentator who's been like
talking a lot throughout the matches
suddenly got really quiet
and he said hmm that's a very strange
move
and I knew then that something really
interesting has just happened in from my
eyes
that this is gonna change something the
South Fargo has made something that
we're gonna remember forever and sure
enough this move turned around the game
for alphago and leading Alpha go to win
one of the matches
so go players today continue to analyze
this move and still discuss people talk
about this is not the move a human would
Phantom
so the question is how did alphago know
this is a good move
my dream is to learn something new by
communicating the machine with machines
and having a conversation
and such that Humanity will gain some
new angle to our important problems like
medicine and Science and many others
and this is not just about discovering
new things if you think about reward
hacking
you have to have a meaningful
conversation with somebody to truly
figure out what their true goal is
so in a way solving this problem is a
superset of solving AI safety too
so how do we have this conversation
conversation assumes that we share some
common vocabulary between uh that that
exchange to exchange meaning and
ultimately the knowledge and naturally a
representation plays a key role in this
conversation on the left and we can
visualize this on the left we say what
this is a representational space of what
humans know on the right what machines
know
here in left Circle there will be
something like this dog is Fluffy and
you know what that means because we all
share somewhat similar recovery
but on the right we have something like
move 37 where we humans yet to have a
representation for
so how do we have this conversation our
representation space needs overlap and
the more overlap we have the better
conversation we're going to have humans
are all good at learning new things like
here everyone is learning something new
so we can expand what we know by
learning new Concepts and vocabularies
and doing so I believe will help us to
build machines that can better align
with our values and our goals
so this is the talk that I gave if
you're curious about some of the work
we're doing towards this direction I
highly recommend it's a YouTube video I
clear keen on half an hour you can fast
uh do a best feed
but today I'm going to talk more about
my hopes and dreams
and hopefully at the end of the day your
hopes and dream is there
so first of all
I'm just gonna set the expectation so at
the end of this talk we still don't know
how the move 37 is made okay sorry
that's going to take a while
in fact the first part of this talk is
going to be about how we move backwards
in this progress
in in terms of making this progress in
our journey and still very very small
portion of our entire Journey towards
understanding move 37
and of course this journey wouldn't be
like a singular path there will be lots
of different branches coming in core
ideas like Transformer helped many
domains across they will be similar here
so I'm going to talk in the part two
some of our work on understanding
emerging behaviors in reinforcement
learning
and all the techniques that I'm going to
talk about is going to be in principle
applicable to NLP
so coming back to our move our dreams
and hopes and dreams 37.
so let's first think about how we might
realize this dream
and taking a step back we have to ask do
we have tools to First estimate what
even machines know
there has been many development in
machine learning last decade now to
develop tools to understand and estimate
this purple circle
so is that accurate
unfortunately many Recent research
showed that there's a huge gap between
What machines actually know and what we
think the machines know
and identifying and bridging this Gap is
important because these tools will form
basis for understanding that move 37.
so what are these tools how many people
familiar with sale in cmaps
a lot but you don't have to explain what
it is so saliency map is one of the
popular interpretability methods for
Simplicity let's say an imagenet you
have an image like this you have a bird
the explanation is going to take a form
of the same image but where each pixel
is numb with associated with a number
that is supposed to
imply some importance of that pixel for
prediction of this image
and one definition of that importance is
that that number indicates how the
function looked like around this pixel
so for example if I have a pixel I XJ
maybe around XJ the function moves up
like the yellow curve or function is
flat or a function is going down like
the green curve
and so if it's flat like a like a blue
curve or red curve maybe that feature is
irrelevant to predicting bird maybe it's
going up then it's maybe more important
because the value of X increases and the
function value goes up function value
here like a prediction value
so let's think about what are the few
ways why this Gap might exist there are
fewer is not exhaustive they're overlap
a little bit but helpful for us to think
about maybe assumptions are wrong so
this alien again these machines that we
train Works in a completely different
perhaps completely different
representational space very different
experiences about the world so assuming
that it sees the world that we do just
like we do like having the gesture
phenomenon there's few dots humans are
have tendency to connect them maybe
machines have the two maybe not so maybe
our assumptions about these machines
were wrong
maybe our expectations are mismatched we
thought it was doing X but it was
actually doing y
or
maybe it's beyond us maybe it's showing
something superhuman that humans just
can't understand
I'm going to take a deeper into one of
uh some of these our work this is more
recent work
so again coming back to the earlier
story about Salient cement we're going
to play with some of these methods
now uh in 2018
we
stumbled upon this phenomenon that was
quite shocking which was that we were
actually trying to write some different
people again people of Christians here
but we were testing something and we
realized that train Network and
untrained network has the same very
similar as alien cmap in other words
random prediction and meaningful
prediction were giving me the same
explanation
so that was puzzling we thought we had a
bug but it turned out we didn't it
actually is in this thing
indistinguishable qualitatively and
quantitatively
so that was shocking
but then we wondered maybe this one-off
case maybe it still works somehow in
practice
so we tested that in a follow-up paper
okay what if the model had an error one
of these errors maybe it has a labeling
error maybe it has a spheres correlation
maybe that had Auto distribution at test
time if we intentionally insert these
bugs can explanation tell us that
there's something wrong with the model
it turns out that that's also not quite
true
you might think that oh maybe superior's
correlation another follow-up work also
showed that this is also not the case
so we were disappointed
but then still we say you know maybe
there is a there's no theoretical proof
of this maybe this is again a lab
setting test we had grad students to
test this system maybe there's still
some hope
so this is more recent work where we
theoretically prove that some of these
methods very popular methods cannot do
better than random so I'm going to talk
a little a little bit about that
I'm missing one person oh I'm missing
Tang way in the author list I just
realized this is also work with pangwei
so let's first talk about our
expectation what is our expectation
about this tool now the original paper
that developed this method IG and Shop
talks about how IG can be used for
accounting the contributions of each
feature
so what that means is that when the Tool
assigns zero attribution to a pixel
we're gonna say okay well pixel is on
used by the function
and that means that F will be
insensitive if I perturb this X
and in fact this is how it's been used
it in practice this is a paper published
in nature they use the shop to figure
out the eligibility criteria in a
medical trial
what we show in this work is that none
of these inferences that seemed pretty
natural were true
and in fact just because popular
attribution methods tell you anything
about it attribution is X you cannot
conclude anything about the actual Model
Behavior
so how does that work
how many people here do Theory proof
or few great I'll tell you I I learned
about Theory proving from this project
as well so I'll tell you like the way
that that we pursued this particular
work is that first think about this
problem and we're going to formulate
into some other problem that we know how
to solve so in this case we formulate
this as hypothesis testing because once
you formulate in the hypothesis testing
yes or no there are lots of tools in
statistics you can use to prove this
so what is hypothesis the hypothesis is
that I'm a user I got an attribution
value from one of these tools and I have
a mental model of ah this feature is
important or maybe not important
then the hypothesis is that whether
that's true or not
and what we showed is that given
whatever hypothesis you may have we can
you cannot do better than random
guessing invalidating or invalidating
this hypothesis testing
and that means yes it's sometimes it's
right but you don't do hypothesis
testing if you cannot validate yes or no
you just don't because like what's the
point of doing it if you just don't know
if it's as good as random guessing right
and the result is that yes for for this
for this graph it's just a visualization
of our results if you plot true negative
and true positive and line is random
guessing because this is the worst
method that's the best method all the
equal distance is this line methods that
we know shop in IG all all falls under
this line of random guessing
that's bad news
but maybe
maybe this still works in practice for
some reason maybe there were some
assumptions that we had that didn't
quite meet in the practice
so does this phenomenal hold in practice
the answer is yes we did we now have
more image graphs and more bigger models
but here we test two concrete and tasks
that people care about in
interpretability or use these methods to
do recourse or spiritual correlation so
recourse for those are not familiaries
you're getting a loan and you wonder
whether if I'm older I would have a high
chance of getting a loan so I tweak this
one feature and see if my value goes up
or down very reasonable task have people
do all the time pretty significant
implications socially
so for two of these concrete and tasks
both of them boil down to this
hypothesis testing framework that I
talked about
they're all around the random guessing
line over worse than random guessing
so you might say oh no this is not good
A lot of people are using these tools
what do we do
we have very simple idea about this
so
people like
developing complex tools and I really
hope you're not one of those people
because a lot of times simple methods
work who comes Razer but also simple
methods are elegant there's a reason
perhaps a lot of times why they work
they're simple that you can understand
them they make sense so let's try that
idea here so again your goal is to
estimate a function shape what do you do
well the simplest thing you do is you
have a point of interest you sample
around that point and evaluate the
function around that point if it goes up
maybe functions going up if it goes down
maybe functions coming down right so
that's the simplest way you can kind of
brute force it
but then the question is how many
samples do we need so here this is the
equation that you're boosting you're
lifting this line upwards that way by
adding that additional term
uh it's proportional to number of
samples the more samples you have the
better estimation you have makes sense
and differences in output how much
resolution do you care do you care point
zero point one to point point one to
point two or do you only care zero slope
to like slope one that's resolution that
you care about and number of features of
course so if you worry about making some
conclusion based on function shape
sample
easy
so
can we infer the Model Behavior using
this popular methods the answer is no
and this holds both theory and practice
we're currently working on even bigger
models to to show just like again you
know again empirical evidence that yes
it just really doesn't work please you
know think of think twice and three
times before using these methods
and also a model dependent sample
complexity if your function is kind of
crazy of course you're going to need
more samples so what is the definition
of how do we characterize these
functions
and finally we haven't quite given up
yet because these methods have a pretty
good root in economics and and sharply
values and all that so maybe they're a
lot narrower condition where these
methods work and we believe such such
condition does exist we just have to
figure out when
once we figure out what that condition
is then in given function I can test it
and say yes I can use shop here yes I
can use IG here or no I can't
that would be still very useful so
ongoing work
before I go to the next one any
questions
yes do the findings you have about the
these models like does it only applied
in computer-bit models or does it
applies any model and that has a
function
yeah very simple simple actually
simplest proof that can show simply any
function this holds
any other questions
it's wonderful yeah this relate to you a
lot but like it's almost seems like for
the last couple of years they're being
at least dozens maybe hundreds of people
writing to people through the Shipley
values I mean it
if you're guessed that most of that work
that's invalid or that a lot of it might
be okay because the the point of a
condition where it's all right right off
of you being there
so two answers to that question my
hypothesis testing results shows that
it's random right so maybe in the
optimistic case optimistic case 50 of
those papers
you hit it
and on the other side on the second note
even if maybe shop wasn't perfect maybe
it was kind of wrong but even if if it
helped human at the end task whatever
that might be Health doctors to be more
efficient identifying bugs and whatnot
and if they did the validation correctly
with the right control testing setup
then I think it's good you know you
figure it out somehow how to make this
noisy tools together work with human
interlude maybe and that's also good and
I personally really like shop uh paper
and I'm a I'm a good friend with Scott
and I love all his work it's just that I
think we need to narrow down our
expectations so that our expectations
are better aligned
all right I'm going to talk about
another word that's a kind of similar
flavor
now it's an NLP
so this is one of those papers just like
the many other papers that that we we
ended up writing one of those
Serendipity paper so initially Peter
came up as an intern and we thought
we're gonna locate ethical knowledge in
this large language models and then
maybe we're gonna edit them to make them
a little more ethical so that was a goal
and then we thought oh the wrong paper
from David Bowie and I also love David's
work and let's use that so that's the
start of this work
but then we start digging into and
implementing the realm and like things
didn't quite line up so we do like
sanity check experiment after sanity
check and we ended up writing completely
different paper which I'm going to about
to talk to you about
so
the this paper the Rome for those who
are not familiar which I'm going into
detail a little more detail in a bit is
about editing a model so you first
locate a knowledge in a in a model like
the Space Needle is in Seattle that's a
factor knowledge you locate them you
edit them because you can locate them
you can mess with it to edit that fact
that's like the whole promise of it in
fact that's a lot of times how
localization or editing methods were
motivated in their literature
but what we show is that this assumption
is actually not true
and to be quite honest with you like I
still don't quite get why this is not
related and I'll talk more about this
because this is like a big question uh
to us this is a pretty pretty um active
work
so substantial fraction of factual
knowledge is stored outside of layers
that are identified as having no
knowledge
and you can you can you can see you can
you will see this a little more detail
in a bit
in fact the correlation between where
the location where where the facts are
located and how well you will edit if we
edit that location is completely
correlated uncorrelated so they have
nothing to do with each other
so we thought well maybe it's the
problem with the definition of editing
what we mean by editing can mean a lot
of different things so let's think about
different ways to edit a thing so we try
a bunch of things with a little success
we couldn't find an editing definition
that actually relates really well with
localization methods like in particular
with ROM
so let's talk a little bit about Rome
how Rome Works super briefly there's a
lot of details missed out on this side
but roughly you will get the idea so
Rome is Magneto 2022 uh they have what's
called causal tracing algorithm and the
way it works is that you're going to run
a model on this particular data set now
counter effect data set that has this
Tuple subject relation and object the
space needle look is located in Seattle
and so you're going to have a clean run
of the Space Needle is in Seattle one
time you stole every single module every
single value activations
and then in the second run which they
call corrupted run you're going to add
noise in those Space Needle is or or the
space
then then you're going to intervene at
every single one of those modules
as if from by copying this module to the
corrupted run so as if that particular
model was never
interrupted never a noise was never
added to that module
so it's a typical like intervention case
where you pretend everything else being
equal if I change just this one module
what is the probability of having the
right answer so in this case probability
of the right answer Seattle given that I
know it's the model and I intervened on
it
so at the end of the day you'll find
graph like that where each layer and
each token has a score How likely it is
if I intervene on that token in that
layer how How likely is it that I will
recover the right answer because if I
recover right answer that's the model
that's the module that's stored on
knowledge
really reasonable algorithm I couldn't
find technical flow in this algorithm I
quite like it actually
so but but when we start looking at this
using the same model that they use GPT
gptj we realized that a lot of these
facts so so Rome uses just layer 6 to
edit because that was the supposedly the
best layer across this data set to add
in most of the factual knowledge is
stored in layer 6 and they showed uh
editing success and whatnot
but we realized the truth looks like the
graph on the right so the red line is
the layer 6 their extension paper called
memet and it's multiple layers that's
the Blue Line blue region
the black bars are histogram of where
the knowledge was actually peaked if you
test every single layer and as you can
see not a lot of facts fall into that
region so in fact every single fact has
like different regions that where it
peaked so layer six for a lot of facts
weren't the best layer
what the editing really worked it really
works and we did we were able to
duplicate that results so we thought
what do we do to find this ethics
ethical knowledge how do we find the
best layer to edit so that's where we
started but then we thought you know
what take a step back we're going to
actually do alternative check first to
make sure that tracing effect the the
tracing effect is the localization
rip implies better editing results and
that's when everything started to
falling apart
so let's define some metrics first the
edit success this is the rewrite score
same score as roam paper used that's
what we use and the tracing effect this
is localization
is probably you can beat the due to the
slide
so when we plotted the relation between
tracing effect and rewrite score the
local uh the the editing method Redline
applies the perfect correlation
and that was our assumption that there
will be perfectly correlated and which
is why we do localization to begin with
the actual line was yellow
it's close to zero it's actually
negative in this particular data set
that is not even on correlated it's like
anti-correlated
and we didn't stop there we were like we
were so puzzled we're gonna do this for
every single layer and we're gonna find
R square value so how much of the choice
of layer
versus the localization the tracing
effect explains the variance of
successful edit
if you're not familiar with r squared r
squares like a think about it as an
importance of a factor
and it turns out that layer takes 94
dressing effect is zero zero one six
and so we were really opposed that we
were like scratching our head why is
this true
but it was true across layer we tried
all sorts of different things we we
tried different model we tried different
data set it was all like roughly the
case so we were at this point we
contacted David and we start talking
about and and we resolve them they
acknowledge that this is a phenomenon
that that exists you know
so apart from the layer the other way in
which localization can happen is are you
looking at the correct token is that the
other like corresponding yeah yeah in
this graph the token
so the added benefit of the rest of the
localization could only help you look at
which is the correct subgroup token is
that it yeah yeah and so looking at any
of the software tokens it sort of finds
what I should think of yeah yeah just
layer layer is the most biggest thing
that's the only thing you should care if
you care about editing layers
in fact don't worry about localization
at all it's extra wasted carbon uh
climate effect yeah so that was that was
our conclusion
but then we thought you know maybe the
particular definition of edit that they
used in the room was was maybe different
maybe maybe there's exists a definition
of editing that correlates a lot better
with localization because there must be
I'm still puzzled why is this not
correlated so we tried a bunch of
different definitions of edits you might
inject an error you might uh you might
invert reverse the tracing you might
want to erase effect you might we might
want to amplify the fact all these
things like maybe one of these will work
you did it
so the craft that you're seeing down
here is R square value for four
different methods and this wasn't just
the case for Roman memory it was also
the case for fine tuning methods
that you want to look at the difference
between blue and orange bar represents
how much the tracing effect influenced
our Square value of the tracing effect
as you can see it's ignorable they're
all the same
you might feel the effect forcing the
last one has a little bit of Hope but
still
compared to the impact of layer choice
of layer it's ignorable
so at this point we said okay well we
can't locate the ethics no ethical
knowledge at this project we're going to
have to switch the direction and we end
up doing a lot more in-depth analysis on
on this
so in summary does localization help
editing no
the relationship is actually zero for
this particular editing method that from
what I know is pretty state-of-the-art
and the counter of counter effect data
it's not true
are there any other editing methods that
correlate better no but if somebody can
answer this question for me that will be
very satisfying like I feel like there
should start something still be
something there that we're missing
but causal tracing I think what it does
is it reveals the factual information
when the Transformer is passing forward
I think it represents where's the fact
when you're doing that
but what we found here is that it has
nothing to do with editing success those
two things are different and we have to
resolve that somehow
but a lot of insights that they found in
their paper is still useful like the
early to mid-range NLP representation
last token there they represent the
factual something we didn't know before
but it is important not to validate
localization methods using the editing
method now we know and maybe not to
motivate editing methods using via
localization those are the two things
now we know that we shouldn't do because
we couldn't find a relationship
any questions on this one before I move
on to the next one
you're not shocked by this
I am shocked by this I'm still so
puzzled like it should be there should
be something I don't know
all right
so in summary of this first part we
talked about why there the Gap might
exist and what she what machines know
versus what we think machines now there
are three hypothesis there are three
ideas assumptions are wrong maybe our
expectations are wrong maybe it's beyond
us there's a good quote that says good
at good artist still I think good
researchers doubt we have to be really
suspicious of everything that we do and
that's maybe the biggest lesson that
I've learned over many years that once
you like your results so much that's a
bad sign
like come back like go home have a beer
go to sleep and next day you come back
and like put your paper in on your desk
and think okay now I'm gonna review this
paper
how do I criticize this one what do I
not like about this paper right that's
the one way to look at criticize your
own research and and that will improve
your thinking a lot
so let's bring our attention back to our
hopes and dreams it keeps coming back
so here
I came to realize maybe instead of just
building tools to understand perhaps we
need to do some groundwork what do I
mean well this alien that we've been
dealing with trying to generate
explanations seems to be a different
kind so maybe we should study them as if
they're like new species in the wild
so what do you do when you observe a new
species in the wild you have a couple
ways but one of the ways is to
observational study so you saw some
species in the wild far away first you
just kind of watch them you watch them
and see what are they like what are
their habitat how they what what do they
what are their values and whatnot
and second way you can actually
intervene and do a control study so we
did something like this with
reinforcement learning setup
I'm going to talk about these two papers
first paper
emergent behaviors in multi-agent
systems has been so cool who who saw
this hide and seek video by open AI
yeah it's so cool if you haven't seen it
just Google it and watch it it's so
fascinating I'm only covering the tip of
an iceberg in this but at the end of
this hide and seek episode at some point
the agents reveal a discover a bug in
this physical system and start like
anti-gravity flying in the air and like
shooting hiders everywhere a super
interesting video you must watch
so lots of that and also humanoid
football and capture the flag from
deepmind lots of interesting behaviors
emerging that we observed
here's the my favorite one but but these
labels so here these are labels that are
provided by open AI running and chasing
for building and ramp use but and these
ones were that oh human or humans when
painstakingly one by one watch all these
videos and label them manually
so our question is can we is there
better way to discover this emergent
behaviors perhaps some nice
visualization can help us explore this
complex uh complex domain a little
better so that's our goal
so in this work we're going to again
treat the agents like an observational
study like us new species then we're
going to do observational study and what
that means is that we only get to
observe State and action pair so where
they are what are they doing or uh yeah
what are they doing
and we're going to discover agent
Behavior by basically kind of like a
clustering the data that's all we're
gonna do
and how do we do it pretty simple a
generative model have you have covered
the Bayesian generator graphical no
gotcha okay so think about
hi then also what you teach yeah so this
is a graphical model
um think about this as a fake or
hypothetical data generation process so
how does this work like I'm generating
the data I created this system I'm going
to first generate a joint latent
embedding space for that represents all
numbers that represents all the
behaviors in the system
and then I'm gonna for each agent I'm
going to generate another embedding
and each embedding when it's conditioned
with State it's going to generate policy
it's going to decide what it's going to
do what action is given the state and
the embedding pair
and then what that whole thing generates
is what you see the state and action
pair so how does this work well and then
given this you build a model and you do
inference to learn all these parameters
kind of same business as neural network
but it's just have a little more
structure
so this is completely made up right this
is like my idea of how these new species
might work and our goal is to we're
going to try this and see if anything
useful comes up and the way you do this
is one of the ways you do this is you
optimize for a variation lower bound you
don't need to know that it's very cool
actually if if one gets into this
exponential family business uh it's very
cool
CS 228 okay so here's one of the results
that we had it's a domain called mujoko
here we're going to pretend that we have
two agents one controlling back leg and
one controlling the front leg and on the
right we're showing that joint embedding
space Z Omega and z alpha while video is
running
I'm going to try to
put the video back
okay so now I'm going to select this is
a visualization that we built or online
you can you can go check it out you can
select a little space in agent one space
and you see it maps to pretty tight
space and Agent Zero and it shows pretty
decent running ability so that's cool
and now I'm going to select somewhere
else in agent one that maps to kind of
disperse area in Agent Zero it looks
like it's not not doing as well
and this is just an Insight that we gain
for this data only but like I was
quickly able to identify ah this type
mapping business kind of represents the
good running behavior and bad running
behaviors that's something that you can
do pretty efficiently
and now I'm going to show you something
more interesting so of course we have to
do this because we have the data it's
it's here it's so cool so we apply this
framework in the when ai's hide and seek
this has four agent it looks like a
simple game but it has pretty complex
structure 100 dimensional observations
uh five-dimensional action space
so in this work remember that we pretend
that we don't know the labels given by
open AI we just shuffle them in the mix
but we can color them our results with
respect to their labels so again this is
the result of Z Omega and z alpha the
individual agents but the coloring is
something that we didn't know before we
just did it after the fact
you can see in the Z Omega there's nice
kind of
pattern that we can roughly separate
what human what makes sense to humans
and what makes sense to us but remember
the the green and gray kind of
everywhere they're mixed so in this
particular run of open AIS hide and seek
it seemed that those two representations
were kind of entangled
the running and chasing the blue dots it
seems to be pretty separate and
distinguishable from all the other
colors and that kind of makes sense
because that's basis of playing this
game so if you don't have that
representation you have a you have a big
trouble
but in case of like orange which is fort
building
it's a lot more distinguishable in
hiders and that makes sense because
hiders are the ones building the fort
then Seekers don't build the fort so
we're in just a little more entangled in
Seekers perhaps if Seekers had built
more separate for building uh
representation maybe they would have win
this game
so this work can we learn something
interesting emerging behaviors by just
simply observing the system the answer
seems to be yes at least for the domains
that we tested a lot more more complex
domains should be tested but these are
the ones we had
but remember that these methods don't
give you names of these clusters so you
would have to go and investigate and
click through and explore
and if the cluster represents super
superhuman concept this is not going to
help you and I'll talk a little more
about the work that that we do try to
help them but this is not for you this
is not going to help you there
and also if you have access to the model
and the reward signal you should use it
why why dump it
so next part we do use it I'm going to
talk about let's work with Nico and
Natasha and Shay again
so here this time we're going to
intervene we're going to be a little
intrusive but hopefully we'll learn a
little more
so problem is that we're going to build
a new multi-agent system we're going to
build it from scratch such that we can
do control testing but at the same time
we shouldn't sacrifice the performance
so we're going to try to match the the
performance of the overall system and we
do succeed
I had this paper collaboration with
Folks at Sanford actually here in 2020
where we propose this pretty simple idea
which is you have on your own network
why don't we embed Concepts in the
middle of the bottleneck where one
neuron represents three the other
represents stripes and just train the
model end to end
and why are we doing this well because
then at inference time you can actually
intervene you can pretend you know
predicting zebra I don't think three
should matter so I'm gonna zero out this
neuron and feed forward and see what
happens so it's particularly useful in
the medical setting where there are some
features that doctors don't want we can
cancel on and test
so this is the work to extend this to RL
setting it's actually not as simple
extension then as we thought it came out
to be pretty complex but essentially
we're doing that and we're building each
of the concept bottleneck for each agent
and at the end of the day what you
optimize is what you usually do typical
PPO just think about this as make the
make daughter system work plus
minimizing the difference between the
true concept and estimated concept
that's all you do
why are we doing this you can intervene
you can pretend now agent 2 pretend that
you can't see agent 1. what happens now
that's what we're doing here
we're going to do this in two domains
first domain how many people looked at
the uh saw this cooking game before
yeah it's a it's a pretty commonly used
cooking uh domain in reinforcement
learning very simple
we have two agents yellow and blue and
they're going to make soup
they can bring Three Tomatoes they get a
war they wait for the tomato and bring
the dishes a dish to the cooking pot
they get a reward finally their goal is
to deliver as many soups as possible
given given some time
and here Concepts that we use are agent
position orientation agent has tomato it
has Dish etc etc something that's
immediately available to you already
and you can of course tweak the
environment to make it more fun so you
can make it that they have to
collaborate like you can build a wall
between them so that they have to work
together in order to serve any tomato
soup or you can make them freely
available you can work independently or
together
whatever your choice
first uh just kind of send you the check
was that you can you can detect the
emerging behavior of coordination versus
non-coordination so when the impassable
environment when we made up that
environment and suppose that RL system
that we trained worked they were able to
deliver some soups then you see that
when we intervene uh this graph let me
explain this is a reward of an agent one
when we when there's no intervention so
this is perfectly good world and when
there was an intervention this is the
average value of intervening on all
Concepts but I'm also going to show you
each concept soon
if you compare left and right you can
tell that in the right when we intervene
reward deteriorated quite a lot for both
of them and that's one way to see yeah
they are coordinating because somehow
intervening and at this concept impacted
a lot of their performance
but this is what what uh what was really
interesting to me and I'm curious anyone
can guess so this is the same graph as
the one you saw before
but except I'm plotting for intervention
for each concept so I'm intervening team
position team orientation team has
tomato etc etc
it turns out that they are using or
rather when we intervene on team
orientation the degradation of
performance was the biggest to the
extent that we believe that orientation
had to do with subcoordination
does anyone can guess why this might be
the position
there's orientation
yes just a clarification question on the
orientation is that like the direction
that the teammate is producing yes so it
seems like orientation would let you
yes yes that's right yes where were you
when I was when I was pulling my hair
hair over this question yes that's
exactly right and initially I was really
puzzled like why not position because I
expect it to be positioned but exactly
that's exactly right so the orientation
is the first signal that an agent can
get about the next move over the other
Asian because they're facing the pot
they're going to the pot they're facing
the Tomato they're going to get the
tomato
really interesting intuition but some
too obvious to some but I needed this
graph to work that out
and of course you can use this to
identify lazy agents if you look at the
rightmost uh yellow agent our friend
just chilling in the in the background
and he's lazy and if you train our
religion there's always some agents just
hanging out they just not do anything
and you can you can easily identify this
by using this graph if I intervene it it
just doesn't impact any any of their
Rewards
so the second domain we're going to look
at a little more complex domain so this
is uh it's studying inter-agent social
dynamics so in this domain there is a
little bit of tension this is called a
cleanup we have four agents they only
get rewards if they eat apples just
yellow things or green things or apples
uh but if you don't clean the river then
Apple stops through all so somebody has
to clean the river and you can see if
there are four people trying to collect
apples you can just stay someone else's
to wait until someone else to to clean
the river and then collect the apples
and in fact that's sometimes what
happens
and Concepts here again are pretty uh
pretty uh pretty common things position
orientation and and pollution positions
Etc
so
would we first plotted the same graph as
the previous domain
it it it it tells a story so the story
here is that when I intervene on Asian
one
it seems to influence Asian too quite a
lot if you look at these three different
uh graph reward how reward was impacted
when I intervened on Asian one it's
agent three and four are fine but it
seems that only agent two is influenced
same with idle time same with the Intel
agent distance so we were like oh maybe
that's true but we keep wondering
there's like a lot going on in this
domain like how do we know this is the
case
so we decided to take
another step so
we're going to do a little more work
here uh but but not a lot we're going to
fill the graph to discover interagent
relationships this is simplest dumbest
way to build a graph but again I like
simple things so how do you build a
graph well suppose that you have you're
building a graph between movies this is
like not what we do but just to describe
what we're trying to do we have each row
if we want to build a matrix each row is
a movie and each column consists of
features of these movies so length
Jungle of the movie and so on
and the simplest way to build a graph is
to do a regression so exclude I I throw
and then we're going to regress over
everyone else
and that gives me beta
which is kind of coefficient for for
each of these and that beta represents
the strength between uh strengths of the
edges so this movie is more related to
this movie and not the other movie and
ta-da you have a graph it's like dummy
story there's a lot of caveats to you
shouldn't do this with them a lot of
times but you know this is the simplest
way to do it
so we did the same thing here instead
instead of movie we're going to use
intervention on concept C on agent n as
our node
and for to build this Matrix we're going
to use intervention outcome which
wouldn't happen to be available without
our framework
for reward resource collected and and
many other things
and when you build this graph at the end
of the day you get betas that represent
relationship between these interventions
okay
so I had a
graph of that Matrix apparently I
removed before I came over but imagine
there was a matrix
there is a nicely highlighted between
agent 1 and 4 and that only
contradicting the original hypothesis
that we had and this is the video of it
so when we stared at that Matrix it it
turns out that there's no High Edge
strong edges between agent one and two
so we were like that's weird but there
is strong edges between agent one and
four so we like dig deeper into it
watched a lot of uh a lot of sessions to
validate what's happening and it turns
out that the story was a lot more
complicated the ones orientation was
important for four
but when that fails agent 1 and 2 kinda
gets cornered in and you can see that in
the graph agent 4 kind of get a get
agent one and four uh sorry one and two
blue and yellow agent kind of gets in
the corner together they kind of get
stuck and this is simply just accidental
because of the way that we built this
environment it just happened
but but the true the raw statistics
wouldn't have told us this story that
this was completely accidental in fact
there was no correlation no coordination
between agent one and two but only after
the graph we realized this was the case
now this might be one-off case but you
know what a lot of emerging behaviors
that we want to detect a lot of them
will be one-off case and we really want
to get to the truth of that rather than
having some surface level statistics
so
can we build multi-agent system that
enables intervention and performs as
well the answer is yes there's a graph
that shows the red line and blue line
roughly a line that's good news we are
performing as well
um but remember these Concepts you need
to label them or you should have some
way of getting those Concepts positions
and orientation there might be something
that we would love to extend in the
future
before I go on any questions
you shy
[Music]
cool
all right
so I did tell you that we're not gonna
know uh move uh the solution to move 37
I still don't okay I still don't
but I'll tell you a little bit of work
that I'm currently doing I'm really
excited about uh that we started
thinking you know what will this
understanding move 37 happen before
within my lifetime and I was like oh
maybe not but I kind of want it to
happen so we start this is all about
research right you started carving out a
space where things are a little
resolvable and you try to attack that
problem so this is our attempt to do
exactly that to get a little closer to
our ultimate goal or my ultimate goal of
understanding that move 37.
so before that how many people here know
Alpha Zero from T my yes Alpha zero is a
self-trained uh self-trained chess
playing machine that beats that has
higher yellow rating than any other
humans and beats stockfish which is
arguably no existing human can beat
stock fish so in the previous paper we
try to discover human chess Concepts in
this network so when does concept like
material imbalance appear in its Network
which layer and when in the training
time
and which we call what when and where
plots
and we also compare the evolution of
opening moves between humans and Alpha
zero these are the first couple moves
that you make when you play chess and as
you can see there's a pretty huge
difference left is human right is Alpha
zero it turns out that Alpha zero can
master or supposedly Master a lot of
variety of different types of openings
openings can be very aggressive openings
can be very boring could be very long
range targeting for long range strategy
or short range very different so that
begs a question what does alpha zero
know that humans don't know don't you
want to learn what that might be
so that's what we're doing right now
we're actually almost um we're about to
about to evaluate
so the goal of this war is please teach
the world chess champion on new chess
superhuman chess strategy
and we just got yes from Magnus Carlson
who is the world chess champion
he just lost the match I know but but
you know he still he's still champion in
my mind he's still championed in two
categories actually
so the way that we're doing this is
we're going to discover new chess
strategy by explicitly explicitly for
getting existing chess strategy which we
have a lot of data for
and then we're going to learn a graph
this time a little more complicated
graph by uh using the the existing
relationships between existing Concepts
so that we can get a little bit of more
idea of what the New Concept might look
like
and Magnus Carlson uh so my favorite
part about this work I talk about
carving out my favorite part about this
work is that the evaluation is going to
be pretty clear so it's not just like
Magnus coming in inside say oh your work
is kind of nice and and say nice things
about our work no Magnus actually has to
solve some puzzles
and we will be able to evaluate him
whether he did it or not so it's like a
kind of success and fail but I'm
extremely excited this kind of work I
can only do because of Lisa who is a
champion herself but also a PhD student
at Oxford and like she played against
Magnus in the past and many others
chestplates in the world and she's going
to be the ultimate uh pre-super human
filtering to filter out these Concepts
that will eventually get to Magnus
so I'm super excited about this I have
no results but it's coming up I'm
excited yes
generator because it's already so many
puzzles out there so I'm assuming that
there's probably something new
what are the problems
puzzles are actually pretty simple so
the way that we generate concepts are
within the embedding space of alpha zero
and given that because Alpha zero has
really weird architecture so every
single latent layer in Alpha zero has
the exact same position as a chessboard
that's just the way that they decide to
do it so because of that we can actually
identify or generate the board positions
that corresponds to that concept and
because we have MCTS we can predict what
move it's going to make given that board
position because at inference time it's
actually deterministic of the whole lot
plus zero thing so these we have a lot
of board positions and that's all you
need for puzzles you give up board
position and then ask Magnus to make a
move we explain the concept and then
give Magnus more board positions and see
if we can apply that concept that he
just learned
for example
right but it seems like you're kind of
underneath
yeah so the if I were to ask stockfish
to
solve those puzzles that were a
different question because we're
interested in whether we can teach human
not stockfish stockfish might be able to
do that's actually interesting uh thing
that we could do now I think about but
our goal is to just teach one superhume
like if I have for example 10 000
superhuman Concepts and only three of
them are digestible by Magnus that's a
win that would be a big win for for this
type of research
questions
all right yeah so oh so wrap up small
steps towards our hopes and dreams we
talked about the gap between What
machines know versus what we think
machines know three ideas why that might
be true the three different maybe angles
we can try to attack and answer those
questions and the the bridge that Gap we
talked about studying aliens these
machines in observation study or control
study there are many other ways to study
your species uh and I'm not an expert
but anthropology and other Humanity
studies would know a lot better more
about this
and maybe just maybe we can try to
understand move 37 at some point
hopefully within my lifetime through
this chess uh project that I'm very
excited about thank you
[Applause]
you talked about interprecility research
that costs NLP vision and RL
um do you think there's much about first
taking certain interpretability
techniques from one modality into other
modalities
all right
so it depends on your goal I think like
think about fairness research which uh
Builds on strong mathematical foundation
and that's like applicable for any
questions around fairness or hopefully
applicable but then once you if your
goal is to actually solve a fairness
issue at hand for somebody the real
person in the world that's completely
different question you would have to
customize it for a particular
application so there are two venues and
I think similar is true interoperability
like the theory work that I talked about
shop and IG are used across domains like
Vision texts so that theory paper would
be applicable across the domain things
like RL and the way that we build that
generative model you would need to test
a little bit more to make sure that this
works in NLP uh I don't even know how to
think about agents in NLP yet so it will
need a little bit of tweaking but both
directions are fruitful
John has a question
I saw the recent work in which
some amateur go players found a very
tricky strategy to trick up I think it
was alphago and that seemed like a
concept that humans know that machines
don't in that Venn
diagrams about that yeah actually it's
funny you mentioned that Lisa can beat
Alpha zero pretty easily and it's a
similar idea because uh if you you kind
of know what are the most unseen out of
distribution moves are and and he she
can break Alpha zero pretty easily at
least I guess that if Isa Dole had known
something more about AI then maybe he
would have tried to confuse alphago but
the truth is you know it takes a lot
it's a high stake game like he said oh
it's like a the famous star worldwide so
he wouldn't want to make a a move that
would be seen as a complete mistake like
the one that Magnus made couple of days
ago that got on the news feed everywhere
that he made this Taco century-wide
mistake and that's that's probably hurts
any other questions
zero for example I just like building
machine learning
lazy's games really well
um
well these work that I've presented are
pretty you
um but there has been a bit of
discussion in in the robotics applying
potentially these two Robotics and of
course I can't talk about details but
um
uh things that
reinforcement learning in the wild
people worry about or some of the
surprises right if you have a test for
it like if you have a unit test for it
you're never going to fail because
you're going to test before you deploy I
think the biggest risk for any of this
deployment systems is the surprises that
you didn't expect
so my work around the visualization and
others aim to help you with that so we
may not know names of these surprises
but here's a tool that help you better
discover those surprises before someone
else does or someone else gets harm
um this is kind of an open independent
question but I was wondering we're
talking about a lot of ways in which we
try to kind of visualize or understand
what's going on in the representation
inside the machine but I was wondering
whether we could turn it around and try
to teach machines to tell us like what
using our language is what they're doing
and their representations like illegal
representations of ours and then get the
machine to do the translation for us
instead of us going into the English
yeah great question so it's a really
interesting question because um that's
something that I kind of
tried in in my work previous work called
testing with Concept activation vectors
so that was to map human language into
machine space so that they can only
speak our language because I understand
my language and just talk to me in my
language the challenge is that how would
you do that for something like Alpha
zero like we don't have a vocabulary for
it like move 37 then there's going to be
a lot of missing valuable knowledge that
we might we might not get from the
machine so I think the approach has to
be both ways we should leverage as much
as we can but acknowledging that even
that mapping that trying to map our
language to machines is going to is not
going to be perfect because it's a kind
of proxy for what we think like a
penguin is there's a psychology research
that says everyone thinks very
differently about what penguin is like
if I like a picture of penguin everyone
was thinking different penguin right now
right Australia has the cutest penguin
the fairy penguin I'm thinking that
right I don't know how many people are
thinking that so given that like we give
we're so different machine's gonna think
something else so how do you bridge that
Gap extend that to 100 Concepts and
composing those Concepts it's gonna go
out a while very soon so there's pros
and cons I'm into both of them I think
some applications
exclusively exclusively just using human
concepts are still very helpful it gets
you uh halfway but my ambition is that
we shouldn't stop there we should
benefit from them by having us having
them teach us new things that we didn't
know before
but like um I don't know but like trying
to locate like specific strategies in
the embedding space
What are the alternatives I guess I
don't know the Alternatives just because
I feel like the wrong thing
that's possible so like it's like some
transformed space of our embedding space
in Alpha zero maybe it's a function of
uh applied to that embedding space so
thinking about that as a raw Vector is
is a is a dead end could be uh we'll see
how this chess project goes in a couple
months I might I might rethink my
strategy but interesting thought
yeah so I'm a Psychology major and I do
realize that a lot of the stuff will be
trying to hear like at least this is how
we can figure out how our brains work
and so I think that this would there be
um stuff that um use that's applicable
to internal networks and on the contrary
youth English means interpretability
it's in the studies of neural network
will help us understand and stuff for
our own brain yeah I talked to Jeffrey
Hinton uh you know he would really like
this so I believe I believe you probably
know about this history I think that's
how it all started right the whole
neural network is to understand human
brain
um
so so that that that's that's the answer
to your question interesting however in
my view there is some biases that we
have in neuros Neuroscience because of
the limitations of tools like physical
tools and availability of humans that
you can poke in I think that influences
interpretability research and I'll try
to give you an example what I mean so in
you know cat near the the line or the
horizontal line and vertical line neuron
in cat brain so they put the prop in and
figure out this one neuron detects
vertical lines and you can like validate
it's really cool if you look at the
video the video is still online
yeah what is it
yes yes yes uh so why why did they do
that well because you had one cat and a
four poor cat and you had uh we can only
prob a few neurons at a time right
so that that implied a lot of few
interpreportable research actually
looked at or very focused on like neuron
wise representation like this one neuron
must be very special I actually think
that's not true that was limited by our
ability like physical ability ability to
prop organisms but in your network you
don't have to do that like you can apply
functions to embeddings you can change
the whole embedding to something else
override so that kind of uh is actually
a uh obstacle in our thinking rather
than helping
yeah
okay maybe we should call it there
um so for Thursday when you're not
having uh lecture on Thursday
um there'll be Tas in me here so if you
have any you know last minute panics on
your project so I think we might have
some straight inside to help you we
probably won't actually
um
final lecture cs224 in today
[Applause]